two recent false alarms about gunfire on
the las vegas strip caused some panic
leading to the question does breaking
glass actually sound like gunfire well
with the help of cutting edge glass and
mirror here in las vegas we tested out
the theory today in this demonstration
tempered glass was used which is
identical to the glass used in
commercial doors like in the stores and
casinos
the difference between tempered glass
and normal glass is a nail glass breaks
into big shards
making a little bit more dangerous to
break
when it's tempered glass it kind of
breaks within each other or within
itself that's what makes it the safety
glass it's about four times more
stronger than any old glass
and the difference in the demonstration
was not having the glass placed into a
door frame now this was a very
unscientific method to test out the
theory of course she says it doesn't
sound like gunfire why don't you be the
judge see the full demonstration on our
website eight newsnow dot com